starwars dog fighting we're gonna watch
the trailer for Star Wars squadrons
there's EA event happening this week
apparently blue this is like a cinematic
trailer not sure if there's gameplay
involved or not but let's check it out
anyway
PEGI 16
[Music]
[Music]
barrel roll
[Music]
you are the Empire's strength we do not
accept a few calories mayor
vengeance will be out
so beautiful so beautiful
history
the galaxies it's like a recruitment
video yeah
oh my good
[Music]
yeah whoo okay Oh watching is 210
talking about to say this is the way the
rest of the world writes the dates where
it's the day than the month and the
years that's a second of us yeah like I
should have been playing this all right
it's not a gameplay trailer obviously
but I think in terms of like a trailer
alone I love the tone I love them Wonder
I love the mood sometimes I feel like
the game trailers capture the magic and
wonder of Star Wars better than some of
the movies nowadays I thought this was
absolutely just gorgeous to look at what
I thought was interesting is that you
could obviously fight on both sides you
could choose between which side you want
to play as in this game but I thought
for a cinematic trailer I found it
interesting how whenever we were like
looking from the Empire's perspective
that it didn't go all doom and gloom and
dark with them they treated them just
with the same amount of like love and
glory yeah yeah there's a sense of
wonder to play as part of the Empire as
well this confusing propaganda piece
that makes you want to join both sided
that when you go there like Google get
some [ __ ] any music but we didn't do
that oh yeah peel more directly to the
darkness within you or some kind of
elitism yeah than you that the Empire
embodies I mean obviously shot a little
bit darker or like when the person is
talking to all the troopers on the
Imperial side I was wondering at 1:16 is
that wedge antilles
looks a lot like him I'm so used to see
wedge until his face with that helmet
advisers on them but I imagine that
Ximena gives some shining moments to him
right here man get some Easter eggs in
that game in takes place right after
Return of the Jedi
is there an article on this game so
we're looking at one on the birds right
now developed by motive Montreal which
previously contributed to battlefront 2
and anthem Battlefront 2 which I enjoyed
playing in but then again I was just
versing my girlfriend for like five
straight hours the last time I played it
squadrons will let players fly a variety
of Star Wars ships including the x-wing
a Wii and why we newing tie
fire two interceptor type bomber and tie
Reaper fighters that's cool too here
including fleet battles where the goal
is to work with your teammates to
destroy a capital ship as well as more
traditional dogfighting mode that's what
we're here for baby all the game will
offer extension customization options
for both gameplay altering items like
weapons hulls engines and shields as
well as a variety of cosmetics to
customize our cockpit [ __ ] and pilot
appearance the company promises that
everything will be earned solely through
gameplay the way it out of money yeah
freemium yeah multiplayer support
between players and Xbox one ps4 PC
squadrons will also be compatible but V
better be be awesome to play with VR I'm
just gonna go to Dan and Alyssa's and
play with them on their VR headset will
feature a new single-player campaign set
after the Battle of Endor which will put
players into the shoes of pilots from
both the New Republic's Vanguard
squadron and the Galactic Empire is
Titan squadron do you have to be in the
Titan squadron is it like you have to
play a little both or can you choose is
the kind of information I was looking
for here because it's been a long time
since we got in just a pure space battle
game as it hasn't it's been like a long
time while recent Star Wars titles like
Star Wars Battlefront 2 HEPA players in
the cop picks of x-wings TIE fighters
and other iconic vehicles in the
franchise it's been over a decades in
the route since there was a major Star
Wars game devoted to space battles the
most recent being yes 2003 Star Wars
yeah the one on gamecube rebel strike
for Nintendo GameCube yeah a long
pedigree to Starfighter combat games in
the Star Wars franchise most famous
syllabi the x-wing and TIE fighter games
released for PC and the nineteen eyes
that focus on more realistic space
combat it feels a little bit more like
it's in tune with that yeah yeah okay I
was thinking of Rogue Squadron during
this trailer that was it's like I
haven't there a lot of the Star Wars
universe but that's when I actually did
get down with a lot back in the day
because I love that kind of things
jumping into the ship in the world and
yeah being able to pilot it around and
and feel that feeling that you pointed
out during the trailer where you really
are getting that Star Wars quality
transcribed but in a really lucid way
yeah so right now this is cool I know
that when it comes to games like this
one and I remember like the battlefront
qualms that people had
the way that turned out it was Star Wars
Battlefront 2 but that shooter game came
out a lot of anticipation for it the
graphics was amazing but then the
limited options and the pay-to-play
stuff and there's a whole bunch of
grievances that were constantly
expressed by fans when it came to that
game I imagine that this time around
they're gonna be doing whatever they can
to make sure the same level of backlash
is not received for this particular one
like with the company promising that
everything will be earned solely through
gameplay here in this installment of
squadron I imagine I don't mean a lot to
gamers I mean they need to mend that
bridge because EA had wanted their posts
to read it about their plans for that
battlefront 2 game was like the most
downloaded in history and they have to
be aware of that coming towards this oh
of course they are and that's the one
thing I guess that made me wonder is how
much breadth of gameplay and breadth of
you know options you'll have because you
know this definitely seems like it's
gonna lend itself really heavily to
online play you know getting together
with a few of your friends and doing
that sort of thing but will there be
like involved three of some kind or how
many different ways to approach this
will there be and what famous players
might you be able to unlock and how much
of a [ __ ] will will there be a good
amount of places to start playing or
just a couple places to start playing
yeah I didn't get heavily involved with
Battlefront 2 I definitely played it a
few times but you know I didn't like go
all out with it Island rented it for
like a week anyway guys are you guys
excited for squadron's I'm looking
forward to the gameplay trailer that'll
probably help put a better decision in
my hands and whether or not I'll
actually be renting playing at a
friend's house or buying it myself but
what are you guys thoughts on it so far
leave your thoughts
subscribe for the real rejects click the
notification though and last but not
least
I want to shout today a man named Pete
Dunn Pete is working on a lot of things
right now one of them is a novel and he
actually sent me over a quick 10 page
outline of his for a very complex novel
that he is assembling that he wants to
turn into a book series I got to tell
you but I'm really proud of what you've
cooked up we've gone back and forth a
lot on what you so far treated
it's very dark very wildly inventive
well I did have certain questions I know
that you have a lot of the answers sort
of pertaining your mind and heart right
now but dude I cannot wait for you to
dish this novel out I can't wait for you
to put it out there for the world to see
because I don't know what I'm allowed to
reveal I don't know what he's
comfortable me revealing about it it's
dark it's twisted it's morbid but man is
also really cool and a very awesome type
of supernatural sense it kind of its
kind of like Hannibal meets supernatural
meets Constantine I really really am
happy that you are going through this
and the amount of work that you put into
it you got to pat yourself on the back
just even even for this intensive an
outline that you have completed that and
ended up itself is a big part of the
writing process so did I want to
encourage you to keep going at it to
keep writing because you clearly have a
gift and the world deserves to see it
Thank You Pete